listen i want to start by saying you did
such great work in this
and this film really hit me emotionally
and uh
it was really well done but just want to
start with that um
so um i i mentioned to people i was
going to talk to you and before i get
into specific questions about the movie
i wanted to ask
a question from one of our readers
believe his name is
nick stoller um it says
was it harder doing drama or acting
against a turkey puppet voiced by brian
pawson
um definitely
a turkey puppet you they're just you
never know what to expect you know it's
like working with a lion
completely um one of the things that i
think a lot of people don't realize is
early in your career
you worked on social network you got to
work with david fincher
um and i wanted to know what do you
remember what do you remember about
making that film and
getting to work with such a master early
in your career
yeah that was a pretty um
amazing experience i i love
david i love him and i love his work
obviously um and
i would like to be able to work with him
again
that on a job that would last longer
than a day
um but that was
it was amazing it was you know working
with him
and um
uh
what's his name
aaron sorkin sorry um
two of them have really specific ways of
how you
how they work with their actors and so
combining
both of the extremely tricky um
work ethics was it was just
fun and like you know i'd be happy to do
it again
yeah that film is incredible um one of
the things that i really
admire about what you've been doing the
last few years is you've been taking
some really cool
performances like peanut butter falcon
suspiria
um uh bad times and and now this
and i'm curious how have you been
picking your roles or has it just purely
been
on the scripts that are like like on the
scripts that are available at that
particular moment or have you been
looking for particular projects
um uh
it's hard to to have like a real method
of
i don't really know i don't know how i
pick and choose things it's more just
you know
if the script is good and the character
is good
and if the people that are making it the
people involved are good people
and um talented people i think
that's mostly where my decision
process lies is like what is this
experience going to be like and what is
the story that i'm telling and
those are the kinds of things i i think
those are the the through line and all
of the jobs that i choose
uh as i getting into uh our friend um i
really thought you did such great work
in this
um and like i said the film is so well
done um can you sort of talk about
what was it like because i'm not sure if
you read the esquire article what was it
like when you first heard this story
and was it one of these things where
you're like i really want to make this
yeah i am i
i did read the esquire article after i
read the script
and i thought it was just
extremely human and um
beautiful and a sort of little tiny
pocket of like
real love and um
compassion uh and
those are the stories that are so
important to be
told i think especially in you know with
the world the way it is now
you really want to feel like
inspired by your fellow humans as
opposed to completely heartbroken by
them
so that is kind of
what i what i felt about this movie was
like
i want to know more people like like
these people
uh you got to film in fairhope which is
where this story
took place but it also more than that um
i believe when you were filming like the
fountain sequence you had the real
people in the town coming out
and also you're performing in front of
the actual people
that this story is about and as an actor
i'm curious
what is this like for you or what was it
like for you
when you have like matthew possibly
standing there watching you as nicole
yeah yeah that was pretty wild um
i think the the more intense thing for
me was that
nicole's daughters were there and um
they're in the fountain scene and
that was just um
[Music]
something that i i don't know that i can
wrap my head around what they must have
been
feeling or what they you know how that
experience was for them
i think we all felt extremely grateful
for the opportunity to make the movie
and that everyone it was such a small
town that everybody was like
really abrasive of us and and they all
knew what we were doing they all knew
who the real people were they all knew
them like if i went into the coffee shop
they
they would be like oh you know what
nicole used to get this
it was like extremely bizarre you know
but
um uh intense and emotional and
intimate and like not only a vulnerable
role and and performance
but like a very vulnerable experience
it was just like ex like extremely
exposed
obviously this deals with very serious
subject matter but i think one of the
reasons the film
works so well is gabrielle puts in these
moments of levity
like that scene where jason is doing
stand-up in front of the curtain and
you're watching him
can you sort of talk about for people
that might be like i don't know if i can
watch this movie
it's maybe going to be too much of a
downer for me
there's a lot of levity in this and a
lot of human moments
yeah i think that's that's part of why i
loved it so much was
that there is a lot of levity and
and there's you know life is
is heartbreaking and painful but it's
also
if you can have a if you can have that
perspective you can
feel a lot of relief from finding humor
in the pain um
so that that was important and and it's
it's very
smartly written and and jason is
obviously supremely funny and so is
casey and
um jason and i had worked together on
the five-year engagement with the turkey
puppet
and we've been buddies since then so
that's like 10 years of a relationship
and
um and that i think
informed the character's relationship as
well and like
we could improv improvise and riff with
each other and play and
his stand-up scene was actually one of
my favorite moments in life
so far listen i gotta go i'm just gonna
say again congrats on this movie and
your performance
i wish you nothing but the best thank
you